people talking i want community they  want customers they're full of [ __ ]  that's definitely true i'm aware because  i look at people's actions you know how  i built a community i replied to every  tweet i got from 2007 2011. all of them  all of them all of them i used to go to  sleep at 3 4 in the morning consistently  literally replied to all of them used to  reply to all my emails obviously the  numbers got so crazy at some point in my  career but i still to this day engage in  my discord heavy discord's a huge one  huge huge i reply to dms i have a  community  two  text  two nine three one five seven three one  i reply on that plug right hook twitter  i'm incredibly active you wanna build a  community stop being full of [ __ ]  because most people when they say  community mean customers